good morning believe nation today's
message is pursue your interest in life
over to you Nick Woodman
we all have interests and passions for a
reason it's your inner voice telling you
what you should be doing with your life
if you're not pursuing your interests in
life you're not realizing who you really
are and as a result you're not gonna be
as happy as you can be I think a lot of
people don't necessarily pursue their
interests because they don't know how
it's going to work out and that
uncertainty prevents them from taking
any action where honestly a lot of the
greatest business ideas and a lot of the
best personal growth that you'll ever
get in your life is by following your
intuition by following your passion my
doing the things that interest you even
if you have no idea how it's gonna work
out and not putting the pressure on
yourself that it has to work out
especially in the short term when Nick
was looking at starting GoPro he could
have said this is a stupid idea for me
to do look at look at these big
companies you have Nikon and Canon and
Sony and all these big companies are
already making great cameras Who am I to
come up and make my own camera and
compete against these huge players right
that could have been his mindset that's
a lot that's the mindset for a lot of
people but he kept pursuing his interest
to then be able to build a big company
that made him a billionaire because he
followed his interest in his passion
what he was doing I look at myself I
look at this business eternal day and
salsa when I first started in the salsa
world I just dropped in on a class right
I dropped in to learn salsa was an
interest of mine I was curious about it
I didn't set this goal that I had to
have a salsa dance I had no idea on
paper it looked like a stupid idea right
I'm too tall right you don't see a lot
of huge tall dancers I didn't speak the
language I don't understand Spanish and
I still don't I didn't understand the
counting of the music I didn't grow up
learning the moves and it's gonna be way
harder for me as an adult to learn
compared to somebody who grew up with
that right like all of these things that
were against me but the thing that I had
my favor was that I loved it that it
made me come alive and I would always
bet on the ignorant man or woman who
loved what they were doing as opposed to
the person with all the experience who
was just mailing it in who is okay with
mediocre who is okay with settling and
so even if you don't have the knowledge
or the resources or the connections you
can figure all of that out if you have
the passion and so I think too many
people give up on their interest too
quickly because they don't know how it's
gonna work out and they want to live
that stay for life just find a smaller
way to get started and you owe it to
yourself to at least try to explore and
not put so much pressure on yourself to
find the next big thing because you
never know where it's gonna come from if
I went into salsa dancing in that first
lesson and said I will have to make this
my business that I'm gonna launch off
with or I'm not gonna even do it and I
put all that pressure on that first
class I probably would have quit dancing
just like if you go on a first date with
somebody like we either need to get
married or this isn't gonna work at it
like you need time to explore and pursue
and see what's gonna work or not
and so I'm crude you try a bunch of
stuff you get excited about something go
and try it immediately see how it makes
you feel see if it makes you come alive
find a low-risk way to start immediately
and continue to explore to see if it's
the next big thing for you and if it's
not you drop it but it's way safer in my
view to do that than to never explore
anything and just take the so-called
safe path that everybody else has built
for you instead of you building a life
for yourself so the question today today
is I'm curious what interest do you have
in your life that you are not currently
exploring yet what is this what do you
have on your list of I wish I could
blank what is that blank that you
haven't started yet leave it in the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
before this race Oh give me go